Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Unforgiving: A Northern Hymn. Ooh...
lady is over there
We need to go this way so we got the problem because this lady will not leave us alone
But that's ok because we just need to find the hymn that we need to know to be able to do what we need to do. (Mark wat?)
Now there was something at the bell tower, and I don't know if I'm gonna be able to get to the bell tower
I don't even know if there's a way to hide from this lady
I think that maybe if I crouch and don't sprint everywhere
I go and don't jump and go "HOO-YAH!", I think I might be able to get away from this lady
But I don't think that's gonna take place here anytime soon, so we need to get to the bell tower, and we need to-
(Swedish tree whispering)
(Angry Swedish tree yelling)
What did-- What- what- what DID you give everything for? I mean,
it seems obvious that you gave up your freedom and probably your life considering you're a tree now, which is nice I guess-- Ooo..
Oh!
Ohhh, this is what I needed the tongue and the-
(Laughing)
Ohhh!
Now I know why I did those things!
(Melody playing)
Did I get a new tune? I guess I did, huh?
(Forest flute)
(Panic)
Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah!
All right well that's a problem...
Okay, well I'm gonna run this way now!
(Naked lady screams in anger)
All right, okay lady you can calm down there. It's not that big deal. I am pretty cool, and I know
very handsome
But you can stay away for at least a little bit and control yourself because I need to get this all taken care of
And I need to go-- Where the hell did I go? How did I get here-
Think I need to go past the wall? Maybe? A little bit? Just need to tuck behind the wall
And then I need to go that way. Egh. I see her over there, but she's not-
Don't talk about tasting my notes.. Egh-
But I got another melody and I think that might be what we needed to be able to get across this river because if it is...
Then that means we're gonna be able to progress if it's not then it means we're gonna die on the docks because the lady is
gonna stab us in the butt!
But I need to go over to Fire Mountain where hopefully there are a few less trolls
Oh someone was mentioning-- by the way, someone was mentioning that there was another game that seemed to be similar to this one
um- that I played a demo of a long time ago.
It was where you started the game staring up at a moon, and you went into a cave
and you almost died - to what looked like a troll and... not 100% sure about that but..
It did happen so. All right, do I play this here? Do I play the song of your people?
Heard something ..  I don't know what I heard..
(Singing in anxious Mark)
Okay cool. All right, cool. That- Oh, okay. All right, dragon-
Eugh!Ah! Eh!
Oh God, I did the thing though!
No! Owww!
Oh yeah, that's right. That's bad. I remember that. Oh. Yeah, okay, all right, well.. ah...
I remember how that turns us into trees in all such. Ohho!
(Laughs)
I got a plank of wood. If I'd-a known about that, I would have gotten the plank of wood from the WOODS I WAS IN!!!
YOU KNOW I WAS IN WOODS?! ALL THE WOODED AREA!
The woody woods.
Alright fine...
Away I go then...
Sara-nara, ya!
Bon-vou-jay!
Goodby-uouay...
See ya... Alright, off to Fire Mountain I go...
Guess this match ain't doing me no good, better burn my fingernail off a little bit more
Huh.
Well, this is a conundrum because now I got a bite on my arm, and if I- Oh nope, there-- it's not there anymore *laughing*
Oh wait, no, is on the other side or something? I don't know. It's there...
(Forest flute)
What was that sound?
Careful now don't fall in the water now- Nope that's- ooooo...
Ohhh, no, it's that thing from Game of Thrones! (Mark you're gonna get copyrighted!)
Ah, it's not good...
(Speaking frustrated)
Where'd the Fire Mountain go? Wait, wheerr-wheeer...
Hang on a tick. Is it that game where I'm in a raft in the middle of the ocean because that's where I went c-ha-
That's where I went crazy. I don't want to go crazy here..
In this land of trolls and mythical creatures, but... Ugh, I hate this...
Hi, okay, Hey! Look! I got something too!
You want to play a doodle-doo?!
I'll doodle with you!
You like my doodles?!
Oh-
(Shrek laughing)
Nah.
Hmmmhmmm...
Hmmhmhmmmm
(Shrek laughter fades away)
Okay...
Alright...
Thank you. Thank you very much. Thank you very much. Thank you very much very much
Thank you to you the thanking that I am doing. Thank you very much
Thank you very much
Yeah, alrighty, then well. That is a conundrum that I am currently enduring
So to be able to cure myself, I got a trust a gremlin creature that wants my harp of magical proportions (Seems legit)
But then again, I don't have a lot of attachment to the harp. I kin-ha-
I kind of don't give a shit in this endeavor because I just don't want to bother with anybody here
So you know it is the way that it is....ahyee...
Hello, what words of wisdom do you have for me?
Well you got a silly face. No you've got a- you got silly face. Ooh, what's on your shoulder? Alright, a bite mark.
Ahhhh....
Yep, that's what I suspected.
You bite, you get tree.
Wo-uh-oh.
Kay... so don't trust him??? Well, I mean, it seems like I might be powerless to his uh... will.
So, maybe I should just give it to him and usher the end of the world. You think maybe that's probably a good idea?
-mumbles- Alright whatever you say...
Yeeh..
What do we have here? Forbannelsen
Oh there we go
The curse - when she has given her sharp kiss the poison spreads into the bloodstream in the brats to soul
twisting one's bones
So they sink into the earth at last you transform into an unholy tree forget who you are and become hers forever
Well, that would have been good to know beforehand...
Let me play my magical harp here...
Boink
Uh-huh...
Ahhh...
What did that do? Huh? What did that do? I wonder, What did that do? What did you do, huh?
Can you tell me?
I would like to know...
Because, You know? It's kind of important for this whole endeavor that I'm out of here. It's adventure,
I don't really know why I'm here, or why I rip the tongue out of my brother's mouth and his eyeball
before I even knew I needed them,
but you know it is what it is...
Ahh-- Alright anyway, that burnt. Hello tree. Do you have something to say to me? Tree? Oooh, nice.
Hello
No, nothing, okay. All right. Thank you
I don't know what these are for, I'm collecting like these poster things from all around the island
And they have no meaning to me thus far
but they've gotta be for something like to *inhale*
know something more about the history or the origin of all this there's got to be a deeper meaning to all the things that I'm
seeing in front of me right here, but I just don't know what they are
That's the weirdest thing about it
There's something here, but I don't see
Hello, hello, hi, nobody was it- Oh-
Okay...
I don't want to slither through your dark passages
that sounds patently unpleasant
Do I need to play my harp here? For this tune?
Ding dong ding ding ding
Okay, well, I got those so those are on the gate, so the gate's gonna open for me now? Also. I saw- yeah, you, hi
Little gremlin creature, what is with you? You've got a mouth on you, and I don't like that. You're not a tree!
You're just a-just a stone horror...don't like it. Okay alright. I think I understand...
Uh...
Down F... alright I got it... alright down F. That... sue salue...
Y and down F
Boy this harp sure came in handy
Okay, oh boy more...
Is this is gonna be ring-around-the-rosy and me finding the cymbals and playing 'em a nice jaunty tune?
And then I'm gonna be able to go forward in life? Is that the only thing that I'm waiting for-
Hey, who's creaking out there? You don't need to be creaking up-up behind me ...No no no no that's unnecessary.
I hear things creepin' around-
-troll growls- *Gasp!*
I knew I heard something of which I did not enjoy!
Ohh, this is bad, huh?
Hello...?
*drum sound*
-trying to impersonate the sound-
Buh  Dadada Dada. Who's got a machine gun? Huh?
You better be using it on that big ass troll...
Oh hello, I found you, I found you. Okay hurry up, please... a little faster on the-the withdrawal of the harp...
Ahh
-thunk thunk-
Thunk-thunk? Who's thunking-thunkin'?!
Who's thonk-a-lonkin? Who's tho- *game noise* Ah! Whose got that machine gun?! And who's not killing that goddamn troll?!
Oh my god, does the troll have the machine gun? Oh God I'm royally boned if that is the case.
Okay, No! Hey! Wow!! Hello...friend...that was right there that probably saw me...
-big thunk thunk-
Wha? Is that a didgeridoo? Oh boy, I don't like this...
The ambience is mixing into the reality and I don't like it
Mmm- Nah-
Nope, don't like that. Nope. Nope! Nope! Nope don' like-- ooh do not like.
I see it! I see it! I've got I spy on it! I'm playing a big old game of I spy and I see it!
Eugh, I spy with my little eye, a red circular butt hole over there! That I'm gonna play a harp into.
I could sing into it if it wants.
-troll growling-
Uh-oh, that's oh, that's no good. Okay. I don't know if this is not gonna-
Oh, I don't know- not this-nah, nah ahh the didgeridoo man.
Ahh!
This is a mistake!
Okay alright, where are you? Where are you troll didgeridoo, man? There you are...
-troll growls-
Uh-oh...
Ugh!
Why do they have to be naked you know? At least the Hulk had the common courtesy to keep his pants on.
Eugh...
Do I gotta play one final tune? Oh, I do! Oh, good. Up f something down F
I don't know what it was but I don't think it's gonna be good for me. Okay...
Alright up F- uhh.. up F, diamond, down F, Diamond, P. Okay, I got it.
Uh oh.. uh oh- uh oh- uh OH- UH OH--
Ooowhaaa! I'm gonna hide...
-inquisitive troll growl-
*imitating troll growl*
A curious little scamp, ain't ya?
Uh-oh (x4)
No, No! How?! How?! How?! How? No! No! No! NO! NO!
-voice cracking- I was free and fun and happy!
-troll growls-
Uh-oh uh-oh hgghh-- Ahhhh!!!
Troll please! I don't taste good!  I don't want to be inside of you!
-thunk thunk-
Okay are we good?
No I hear it. I think it's still got a bead on me. Oh! Hi. Well. Oh, that's a problem.
Hello....?
Troll....?
Uh-uh-No! Bwa-bwa-bwa oohhh nooo....
-troll alert growl-
Wa-uh-oh!
Well that's not good. That's not good! Ah! That's not good! I was totally fine!!
Heeeey! Oh, yeee!
Okay, we're fine. We're fine. We're fine. Okay. Okay up F, diamond, down F, Diamond P. Okay
That's what it is, and that's what I'm gonna do. Okay. I got it. I got I got come on, hurry, hurry-- up f-
Diamond, down f, Diamond, Pueeeeh.
Got it!
Open up! You ass blasting bastard!
Euuyeeeee Euyee
Which way you opening? Okay, There we go, alright. We're in (x4)  Okay! Alright! See you dude! You there?
"Oh hi Mark"
Oh-ho, oh that oh, that's horrible. Oh that is- that is awf-- Oh! You're fast! Okay--
-voice cracking- For crawling on one arm-
You're awfully fast mister!
Eugh
Uh-oh
Well that's a problem
All right, I guess I'm gonna just jump right in. Don't care if my imminent demise waits for me down in there.
*inhale* Just gonna jump on in.
Oh! I got an achievement: Forest Ranger, that's good. Do I get a Scout badge?
Oh good....yay, okay. Where am I now?
Check Matchbox. I don't know if I want to...
How many do I have?
Oh, so many. I am *loaded* up with matches. Oh, I am-I am rich with matches. Okay, all right
Who's down here? Say yes. Hello? Ahhh a whole mining operation.
-sounds of cans knocking over, (animal?) screeching-
-more cans knocking over-
That's what I think of your shit! Huh!
Denizens of the darkness, I kicked over your tin cans! Run away and fear me!
I am your demise!
Okay, whatever....uh-oh
Poppa-poppa grater. Daddy's crying.
Looks like daddy's dead. I want to call it like I see it, but I think I see it like I call it.
Okay, so I got to find more of those bastards. What? Oh God...
The Punished - Shh! They can hear you!
-They were imprisoned deep underground the ground, their souls warped, and they succumbed to evil all together. In the dark their eyes withered and they
learn to listen to the whispers of the mountain.
Oh good!
Terrifying babies!-
-that can hear me screaming "Hey babies! Hey!
Hey, you're assholes and I hate you!" How about that? You like that? I didn't think so I didn't think so...
ooh
Dad says we'll go home soon. I don't
know
Desir lackeys of the Norns - diss a female a female spirit of the dead is a slave to fate
They're under the influence of the Norns carry out their wicked will and see to it the threads of life are spun as the three
desire
Okay, then
Alright musical manuscript book harp. Well that would have been good to read
Swedish tales yeah, okay
Hello? Who's here? Who is you?! Who is you?! Huh?
Ooh
No, that's weird, okay, but I'm not gonna question it because I don't question anything
Okay, that's out of power... -distant screeching-
Mmm.
Somethin' tells me that screaming babies are waiting in the darkness
Whatever, let's keep moving I guess. Let's go towards the horrible sounds. -reads note- "I want to go outside" Too bad uh
You can't! You can never escape. Your life is in here now and misery and torment and the darkness-oh
Okay, and what am I supposed to do about that thing? Am I supposed to jump on that?
Ooh- I see the other thing okay. That's over there. I'll come back and get that and play the harp to it sweetly, in its ear...
But for now- Fornad!
Uh-oh
She won't get us here
-baby cries-
I remember what I have to do. I'm not gonna do it now... until I HAVE to do it.
*groans* I don't like this...
I don't want to have to do that again. If you guys saw the demo, you know what I'm talking about, but if you didn't then....
avert your eyes. -reads note- 'They found daddy. I wasn't allowed to look' Eugh, oh my God.
Okay, though well. That's sad-that is-that's very sad. Okay. -reads note- 'Remember all spare parts are kept in storage.' Ah!
Okay! Alright! So, I gotta-I gotta go to storage. Is what I gotta do.
Also wait, I just noticed how on the-on the no not the harp,
but the-the-the match boxes. Is that what I think it is?
It looks like a mother holding a child in her arms and which is awfully ironic for what I have to do now
*more groaning* uhhhhhh I don't wanna...
Okay, here we go
-baby coos-
*inhale* Mmmmmmm...
Alright!
-baby fusses-
Oh okay, alright, ok it didn't work Wow ok! Probably because I don't have any fuel... I gotta douse them with fuel first...?
Mmm. I don't want to. That's not what I want to do. I can't do anything about it.
It's the game that's making me do it!
It's not my desire to do anything!
How long have you been there?
Hello
Alright.. Okay, see ya.
*reading* The Cure - She fell deeply in love with a false god and his corruption flowed through her giving him influence over her and her powers which he
controls by his own will
Ok alright good...
-eerie crying + thunking noise-
Ahh. Okay. Alright well, that's a thing...
Kay...
Alright...
Okay, well I got that one. The other one's over on the cart floating in the middle of the area.
Maybe I can play to it from here?
I'm playing to you!
Playing to you! This is for you up there. Is for you. I got you.
Nothing
A damn dick doodlee. So I got to get up there and I got to do that. Which means, that I got to find some sort
of a fuel because I got to go into the storage and I gotta...
...burn a...tree....alive
And it's weird because, it's conundrum right? Because these people are cursed
effectively completely cursed. They-
may not even be alive anymore. They're existent might be tortured forever
Just as a tree until they eventually die. So maybe, it's a mercy to just-
I don't know, end it. It's kind of like a soma dilemma. Like, is it really life-
after everything that's happened to them? After they've been changed like this, is it a life worth living? Like, it might be life
but is it life worth living? And that gets into moral dilemmas, that I don't want to approach in a fun game
that's supposed to be a relaxing, adventure away from the stresses of real life.
Okay, alright well, let's go forward first.
Uhhgh...
Oh well. It is what it is and we're gonna face it no matter what we do. Oh look these are boxes! Okay good!
Oh, look! It's a bunch tunnels-why am I here? Why am I here? Why did I have to come here?
Why did I have to be addicted? Why did my brother have to kidnap me? Whaaaaoooo...
I got so many flashbacks to the amnesia water monster. Augghh!
Ohhh-- I hate it (x4)
-water splashing behind Mark- I HATE IT! OH! I HATE IT!
OH! I HATE IT!
I hate everything about it. That rock looks like a face!
Auggh!
Okay, we're fine...
Okay we're fine, we're totally fine. Everything's fine. Everything's 100% cool.
Great, why did I do that and why did I go there? Why-what is with these giant piles of magic? Huh?
What's with all them, huh?
uh
What do I have to do with any of this? What do I have to do with any of this?
Why is this my responsibility? Why did I go in a big circle? I didn't do what I needed!
Did I?
Why is the music kickin' up?!
Okay
Well what's the point of that?! Did I go in a big loop?!
No? Yes?
Cloud of razor blades -The not trauma is a creature with sharp claws in an outer most dangerous beak they can be very dangerous
specifically in large numbers
Okay
Well birds, how are they gonna get down here? In this horrible place that I find myself in.
Oh, what is that...
A box of medical supplies
Bags-- oh, this is a dead end!
Then why am I here? So, this isn't where I came from so this must be a way through to somewhere else
Whoa? What are you?
Oh..
Whaaat is in here? Anything good? No?
Oh. Ahhhhh
Secret, secrets. I definitely haven't been collecting all those but..
Oh well...
I don't wanna-- No, no. Okay, see you do that weird thing where you say you where you get loud, and I don't like it!
No I like it none!
Hey! Oh! Hi!
I'm trying to stop! Currently, presently!
I am *very* injured!
You gonna do that again?
No? Okay, alright, that was just a one-time thing then I guess? Why?!
Why would you do that? What am I doing in here? What's with all the light?
*in rising pitch* Where am I going? Why did I go into this hellhole?! Have I been here before?!
It all looks the same!
I just don't know anymore. I just don't know...
God I just don't know...
Okay, whatever it doesn't matter.
I just got to keep going forward, and hope that a giant arm doesn't reach out one of those things, huh?
It's all I can hope for...
Cause it's weird, it's just sending me in circles. There's got to be a purpose to this! Where am I now?
-reads note- "Bobby was allowed to come with" Somethin' tells me something bad happened to Bobby...
Alright. -reads note- "Can't sleep, they're looking." Are they now?
Who's- .....
Who's uh- ...
Okay, alright. That would have been an excellent- ...
opportunity for there to be many things looking at me up above me.
They who walk in between half dead and half alive.
They dwell forsaken in the deep in hidden places and the areas were the veil between worlds are at its thinnest
Yeah! I think I got a close encounter with one of those. Slapped me in the face...
Alright, okay. 'Labyrinths and rituals in Scandinavia'
Alright! Okay, alright. Scandinavia you say?! Ain't that a- ...
interesting predicament well I turned that on which I'm extremely happy about
very unbelievably happy
Ridiculously beyond happy about that
Okay, alright well I got power on, which should be-
-growling-
*gasp* ewwoahh! Woah!
Woah! Woah! Woah! Woah! Woah... Woah... Woah. Woah.
Alright, so that's how you want to play it huh?
That's ho-Oh...
That's how you want to play it, huh?
Okay, oh, How'd ya get uh- how'd you get up there? Ohhh... how'd you uh- how'd you get up-woah, uh-oh..
Eyee
Better just be the one of you 'cause if it ain't just the one of you I'm gonna be
Primarily upset. Did you did you just make out with someone, or did you slip into the portal?
I'm gonna go for it.
Eugh
Is this is where I need to go? I don't know it's too dark.
Ahhh...
Light. I'm gonna guess go to the light...
Seems like the right-uh oh. Oh, well this ain't good. I'm gonna get slapped. I'm gonna get slapped. Imma get slapped!
I'mma get slapped! Okay, I'm not slapped.
God, if I was in this situation
If me really me was in this situation where I had to explore this dark and dank tunnel all by myself
I wouldn't. How do-how would-how would anyone have the willpower to just keep sprinting forward into the darkness not knowing anything?
-monster growls-  Hey!
Especially if there were monsters lurking around the actual corners! How would anybody?
Nobody would!
Nobody would! Nobody would be able to go where they needed to go! -monster off in the distance- Sprint (x8) Duck!
-monster growls-
Hey! Hi!  Oh! (roughly x8)
I'm gonna go now! Whoo! Whaa! Okay. Don't slap me! Don't slap me! My dancing candle.
Okay, we're fine. I think we're fine
That's a lot of moaning happening behind me. I would appreciate if you did that none...
Oh, are you new? Have you been there? Okay. So that's bad, but anyway. That's all the time I got for this episode
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you think down the comments below
I will continue this very soon, so thanks again and as always, I will see you, in the next video!
Buh-bye!